[Musica]
alzata di mano quanti di voi erano
presenti al balletto di questo
pomeriggio
che vedo un po di mani alzate anche la
in fondo grazie che bello direi un po un
ritorno a una sorta di normalità io
purtroppo oggi non ho potuto vedere il
balletto me lo sono perso
sono arrivata poco fa
e voi vi starete chiedendo giustamente
ma come questa deve parlare a un ted e
arriva tardi dai fortunatamente è ultima
ma sapete l'orario del mio talk non è
affatto casuale
gli organizzatori non avevano scelta se
non che aspettare l'ora del crepuscolo
per farmi parlare questo perché io non
ho scelta
oggi non avrei mai avuto la vostra
stessa magnifica libertà di arrivare in
questo giardino magari visitarlo sedermi
socializzare vedere balletto ovviamente
i talk questo perché perché all'interno
del sangue di tutti noi qua presenti
scorre una molecola che si chiama e me è
essenziale per la vita perché trasporta
l'ossigeno in tutti i tessuti per creare
le me come per tantissime molecole
biologiche
dovete immaginarvi una sorta di catena
di produzione dove gli enzimi in questo
caso va beh gli operai a sembrano pezzo
per pezzo fino a ottenere il composto
finito le me ma in noi pazienti affetti
da protoporfiria eritropoietica
la catena s'inceppa e gli operai non
lavorano bene a causa di difetti
genetici rari che colpiscono proprio yen
zini quindi un po di m ovviamente lo
assemblano sennò non sarei qua con voi a
respirare ossigeno ma per la maggior
parte si va a formare proto porfirina 9
che stasera per semplificare chiamerei
proto
e questa protesi va ad accumulare nel
sangue nel fegato e nella pelle di noi
pazienti è una molecola foto reattiva
come sappiamo come ci hanno
inspiegabilmente
la luce bianca visibile da determinate
lunghezze d'onda le proto sono capaci di
reagire in particolar modo alla luce del
blu vi porto un attimo in laboratorio
con me e penso che sia palese a tutti
quanti noi la differenza che c'è tra le
due provette quella con la proto infatti
è rossa le proto sono capaci di
trasformare luce blu e produrre luce
rossa
penso vi starete chiedendo
che senso ha
ebbene il senso non c'è ad oggi
so solo che questa luce che si viene a
generare inizia a bruciare la pelle a
bruciarla dal di dentro la reazione e
rapida non sto parlando di ore 5 10
minuti sono più che sufficienti per
iniziare a sentire i primi sintomi e
ovviamente questo limita la vita di nei
pazienti
pensate a un'azione no normale domani
mattina per esempio svegliarsi e andare
a prendere un bel caffè in piazza oppure
guidare la macchina lunedì per andare al
lavoro oa giocare coi propri figli al
parco per noi queste diventano delle
vere e proprie sfide o meglio delle
cacce all'ombra che poi anche di ombra
cene diversa è da una vita che cerco di
spiegare la differenza tra un ombra e
l'altra
tante volte mi sono sentita dire dai
francesca su un domani abbia visto il
meteo è tutto nuvoloso grigliata no
perché le nuvole si lasciano passare la
luce blu il male arriva oppure è inverno
dai che fa freddo ma il mio problema è
la luce non il freddo col caldo e quindi
oltre a diventare dei sommelier d'ombra
siamo anche dei creatori d'ombra in
questo modo però capite che girare così
con 40 gradi all'ombra
pensiamo solo quanto ci siamo lamentati
per una mascherina e un po anche con gli
occhi degli altri addosso non è facile
poi se funzionasse io ci andrei in giro
sempre così ma vi devo dire la verità
dopo un po la luce passa e il male
sopraggiunge un male indescrivibile che
non conosce antidolorifico l'unica cura
è il lock down ma al buio penso sia
venuta un po di pelle d'oca a tutti
quanti a sentir parlare di lock down
ammessi per noi pazienti questo è un
concetto nuovo ovviamente ma famigliare
parlerei di quarantena dalla luce e lo
interpreterei con un'unica parola limite
il limite infatti per me corrisponde a
quella linea di confine che segna la
fine dell'ombra e l'inizio della luce io
so che di là non ci posso andare
questa definizione ha sempre ovviamente
influenzato tutto della mia vita
carattere esperienza e persino la mia
professione infatti sono ricercatrice al
policlinico di milano e studio proprio
le porfirie e non è un caso
arrivarci come si dice di tante cose
della vita è stato un percorso in salita
per me è stato un percorso tempestato
d'ombre perché di questo che stiamo
parlando no
ombre non solo fisiche ma anche mentali
una prima ombra è la diagnosi spesso
tardiva perché oltre al danno della luce
rossa che ci brucia la pelle
dall'interno c'è la beffa i sintomi sono
spesso invisibili e quindi spiegare alle
persone che ti circondano cosa stai
provando e difficile vi faccio un
esempio io da piccola odiavo la
ricreazione
all'opposto completo di tutti gli altri
bambini e quindi da qui tante etichette
la bambina un po sociale quella mostra
nano
ma spiegare
ma spiegare a tutti questa problematica
era veramente difficile
così ci ho vissuto per 22 anni
all'interno di questi 22 anni ha
collezionato un sacco di etichette
ovviamente come potete immaginare fino a
che un giorno durante il mio percorso di
biologia il professore di biochimica
parla proprio delle porfirie e li ebbe
l'illuminazione
avere il nome il cognome del proprio
male mia liberata da una prima grande
ombra quella dettata dalla non
conoscenza che porta un passato pieno di
stigmatizzazione sociale che poi
chiamiamolo bullismo che facciamo prima
un altra ombra el'adattamento ti svegli
e un certo giorno e ti chiami in un
altro modo pensate solo dover rifare
tutti i documenti
quindi il paziente si deve iniziare
adattare di nuovo al suo nuovo nome e
cognome
esistono vari modi per farlo io ho preso
l'argomento di petto e oltre a conoscere
il nome il cognome ho voluto conoscere
ogni meccanismo molecolare che
caratterizzava il mio male
questo ovviamente il mio percorso
personale ma ho potuto ascoltarne
tantissimi altri grazie a una chat che
abbiamo istituito nel 2016
all'interno del quale ci sono 87 su 180
pazienti
questo diventata una chat di supporto
abbiamo potuto scambiare opinioni ma
soprattutto creare altre parole
collaborazione unione da questo infatti
per esempio è nato un
qua documentario disponibile in rete con
un giornalista che ha la proto
ovviamente è anche una tesi di laurea di
una psicologa e parla proprio di
porfiria
mentre scrivevo questa nuvola di parole
alle mie spalle
vedevo una parola che svettava più delle
altre seppur piccola e la cura dal 2014
abbiamo una cura che previene la
reazione fototossiche
potete immaginare solo la gioia a
provare a non provare
male tutti i giorni ma come in ogni
fantastica storia c'è sempre un ma dal
2016 la terapia purtroppo è limitata ma
non per ragioni che sentiamo spesso oggi
legate ai vaccini tipo sicurezza ed
efficacia ma per dei processi complessi
che prendono il nome di processo
l'approvazione del farmaco e qui quindi
calanna nuova ombra dovuta proprio al
lato oscuro di questo processo che è
composto da tanti meccanismi difficili
come politica economici sociali
ma cosa fare come agire io nella mia
vita ho imparato a reagire e così ho
iniziato per esempio a divulgare pur non
sapendo farlo ho studiato nuovamente
grazie alla federazione italiana
malattie rare che cosa significa proprio
questo processo da cosa è composto ma
soprattutto mi sono esposto a livello
nazionale e internazionale
ed è proprio qui che ho trovato altri
tre scienziati che come me hanno la
proton
assieme abbiamo dato origine a un
network che proprio prevede la tutela
del nostro farmaco assieme abbiamo
aperto petizioni siamo stati a congressi
scientifici
abbiamo fatto divulgazione ma cosa più
importante siamo stati a l'ormai
famosissima e nota agenzia europea del
farmaco proprio a discutere del nostro
processo di approvazione
ma come in tutte le storie belle c'è
sempre un ma nonostante i grandi
successi che abbiamo ottenuto oggi il
farmaco si trova ancora in versione
limitata
questo però a me spinge ovviamente ogni
giorno a fare meglio ed è per questo che
sono qua stasera per condividere la mia
storia
nelle buste che vi hanno dato
all'ingresso troverete infatti un
bigliettino da visita all'interno del
quale non c'è il mio nome il cognome ma
ho lasciato un nome un cognome in bianco
se lo vorrete in un momento di
riflessione
potete scrivere il nome il cognome di
una vostra ombra di un vostro limite
io ho imparato che la conoscenza la
consapevolezza sono i primi grandi passi
che possono spostare quella linea di
confine che divide quello che oggi è
un'ombra e quello che domani può essere
un po più luminoso
[Applauso]